my name is Danny Thompson I'm the CEO
and founder of face me and face me as a
company that has build the world leading
digital human platform which is all
about creating an emotional connection
in a digital world one of the challenges
for customers particularly as they're
interacting more more digital channels
and not with humans is how do I know
that you understand me how do you
personalize an experience to me how do
we create better man and machine
interfaces because they're becoming such
a common part of our life we've seen
just this incredible response based on
the fact that our face is probably the
most universal interface that's ever
existed anyway so it's been really
interesting just learning around how
people enjoy conversation how they
actually create empathy themselves for a
digital human we're a startup company we
provide this as a subscription and our
whole vision is around making this
incredibly easy for any organization to
consume and build experiences using
digital humans so as a global company
with global customers you know cloud is
supporting that need both in the
geographical sense and IBM cloud helps
us with that I believe the interface
between man and machine is going to
change dramatically in the next five to
ten years you're going to see that more
humanized and more personalized than
ever before that's what we're super
excited about and that's our vision for
the future
[Music]
you